all right last one it's only offensive
when men this is fantastic um
i'm just gonna let it play this is kevin
samuels
i can say i don't want no scrubs
you know people say if he can't buy you
a birkin bag kick him to the curb but if
i just happen to say that you weigh more
than men at your height that's offensive
when did we become that world
he's right
he's right why why is it
that women can pick on men
and they do oh you're this you're fat or
he's a little i don't know
his
he's balding he's gonna go bald oh i
don't know his nose hairs because he
dresses like it's what is it 1960 you
know the things women say they're not
nice men have to just absorb that stuff
a lot of times right because they're
supposed to be like oh tough guy you're
not going to go off and cry so women
just spew
criticism
right you know it but if the guy turns
around if you say to him before you
leave the house does this make me look
fat
he's got to say no even if you got that
jelly doughnut belly hanging over the
jeans
you know it with the little belly button
in between you know it right
he's got to say no
or he gets punished or you know what
happens tears
you run into the next room there's a fit
there's rage you don't wind up going out
he's got to suffer and figure out a gift
to buy you to compensate for what was
probably the truth so then people say to
guys don't don't tell women the truth
lie no
no
grow a backbone if you ask somebody a
question expect an answer you got to be
able to to take it if you can dish it
so this this stuff he's right about this
ladies
he's right so if you you know you got to
be able to take it if you want that
dynamic then you got to be able for him
to say like hey you
you're too [ __ ] on your
instagram maybe you are
oh you can say to him xyz about his
physique or his hair or oh you you know
it you see it all the time oh did you
get your hair cut
and the guy's like yeah
you did
he's like yeah and you're like
maybe you should like try a different
guy
reverse that you went and got your hair
cut and he says to you
did you get your haircut and you're like
yeah and he's like you did
and you're like
yeah and he's like maybe you should try
a different guy
let that sit for a second though absorb
it because women say it with ease and
they expect guys to just be resilient
and you know what sometimes you may hurt
a feeling or two because it's mean what
you're saying
but if they throw it back at you
suddenly you're like
he was disrespectful to me
you call your friend you talk about it
you dissect him
you gotta find another man he can't talk
to you like that
meantime you don't analyze the way
you're talking to him so i'm just saying
if you're willing to put it out there
and you're willing to be critical you
better be able to take criticism and if
you ask a question i'm sorry ladies if
you ask the question do i look fat you
should be prepared for an answer if you
like the short clip you can catch
another one here or you can catch the
full episode right here
[Music]